the return Dancing with the Stars and  there's been some big ballroom shake up  this has met Nancy you know i love my  dancin i can tell you do this is gonna  be the first topless season in five  years and dancing in rain no Derek no  Julie Ann what's dancing gonna do  Derek's taking the season off to bring  singing in the rain to Broadway he did  his best Gene Kelly at the weinstein  company's pre-oscar bash while Juliana's  leaving her judging post to pursue other  projects and may be planning a wedding  to hockey player Brooks like ABC's  strategy for a huff lyst season judge  Len Goodman is coming back another plan  classic sitcom stars they've cast Kim  fields Judy from the facts of life and  full house star jodie sweetin  you